- [Presenter] The first
solar panels were invented
in America in 1954,
and yet, it's been China
that's been better able
to capitalize on the technologies.
- China was one of the first countries
to realize the potential of solar panels.
China actually took it
and really commercialized
it at a large scale.
- [Presenter] Now, China controls over 80%
of the global solar panel supply chain.
While the United States,
manufactures virtually none
of the required components
for solar panel production.
So to effectively compete with China
in solar panel manufacturing,
the US is prioritizing
building up its supply chain,
basically, from scratch.
Today, the US has less than half
of the solar capacity that China does,
and of the solar panels that
are installed in the US,
nearly four out of five of them
are from Chinese companies.
- China has such a headstart
when it comes to solar
panel manufacturing,
it's because they dominate the
entire global supply chain.
- [Presenter] That's
because in recent years,
China has spent almost 10 times as much
on solar manufacturing than
the US and the EU combined.
And of the world's top 10
largest solar manufacturers,
seven are Chinese, only one is American.
That stark difference plays out
in each country's energy mix.
According to the EIA,
solar energy makes up 12%
of China's total electricity
generation capacity,
yet, it only makes up about 3.4%
of the US' total electricity
generation capacity.
- It was really this idea that
they were just going to shoot
for the moon and go big, and
that has huge implications
and dragged frankly, the rest of the world
into this clean energy as a
real option, not a play thing.
- [Presenter] But one key area
where the US has an
advantage is silica sand,
the primary mineral used
for solar generation.
It exports about $470
million worth of the mineral,
and China is the world's
largest importer of silica sand,
importing it mainly
from the United States,
Australia, and Indonesia.
To make a panel, silica
sand needs to be refined
to create purified silicon,
which is shaped into ingots
and sliced into thin wafers.
The wafers are cut into
cells and panel manufacturers
then assemble the cells in a frame
and add circuitry to create
a finished module or panel.
But even though the United
States has the raw materials,
it has no manufacturers
of silicon wafers or cells
used for solar panel production.
- Manufacturing isn't just
some Lego play, right?
It's about figuring out how
to do something quicker,
more efficiently, better than others.
- [Presenter] Because China's
able to produce solar panels
at a significantly lower
cost in global markets,
the few US solar
manufacturers that do exist
heavily rely on importing
components exclusive to China
and then assembling them domestically.
- The reason China has been able
to bring down costs
actually and sustain quality
of solar panels, they decided
that they were gonna build
bigger plants, much bigger in size
than the United States
had in the early days.
They incorporated new
manufacturing approaches
including robotics, and
they were so much larger
with so much less human interaction
that they were able to scale up.
- And this is actually China's real skill,
how to make things and make
it commercially viable,
and then cheap and accessible.
- The Inflation Reduction Act
is also the most
significant investment ever
in climate change.
- [Presenter] The Inflation Reduction Act
passed in August, 2022, hopes
to accelerate the transition
to a clean energy economy.
For solar manufacturing,
that means incentives
for boosting panel
installations and tax credits
for manufacturing solar
components in the United States.
- We, in the US, have never
had really industrial policy
to support that kind of
manufacturing, right?
It's only now with the
Inflation Reduction Act
that we have the kind of
domestic industrial policy
that will support solar manufacturing
and storage manufacturing here in the US.
- Already, the Inflation
Reduction Act has led First Solar,
the biggest solar panel maker in the US
to spend $1.2 billion to increase
its US manufacturing capacity by 75%.
- If we're going to continue
to scale up the industry
in order to address the climate crisis,
we need to bring more of
that manufacturing home,
and we're doing it.
- [Presenter] But because
China is ahead by so much,
there is debate whether the US
should try to invest money in the sector.
- The United States may not be able
to actually really catch up
with China as much as that.
It may just be able to
onshore some of the skills,
so that it can do it itself.
- I remind people that energy
is used in everything we do,
our electricity, our
transportation, our infrastructure,
our communications, our
agriculture, everything.
(gentle music)